ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono falli già oggi
sono qui con i ragazzi sono qua a caso
di jacopo coinvolto questi due bei
ragazzi perché oggi faremo rimani scrive
coach dell'arrivo di approviamo un po di
erotismo a questi video se noi click non
arriva il quiz sui fori jail che nessuno
riesce a fare purtroppo di tutti youtube
perché invito nessuno che mi segue va
voi ragazzi che io non so niente mi fa
un grande grande fan di lorenzo io so
tutto cominciamo a ragazzi sicuramente
come viola che iniziare a prendere
mazzate subito da danja prima si prego
allora trovare nella figura come ha
chiamato a far vedere questo video lo sa
il fatto suo
hanno fatto un video videogiocare che
culo leader idv che mai nella mia grande
di panaro bazzano ragazzi in fiore
seguito lorenzo con chi ha buona tra
sfere di napoli su matri
avrei voluto fare delle penitenze che
devo giocare con il tema che mi sentivo
così ogni volta che sbaglia una foto di
quando eri piccolo prima di acqua grazie
a giocare che penitenza fatto nella
terza punta del social feeds i due si è
fatto un tuo agio andato in giro in
mutande si ricorda di pesce bandi
jumping bandi già malaga crediti daniele
fan non lo sappiamo
insomma jacopo non ci sta dentro 7
proprio la mia mappa di just dance mi
sono aver ballato benissimo non per non
averla vista conosciuto in tutto il
mondo
altra foto di alterazione o l'altra cosa
dopo da piccolo era anche appassionato
di videogame si come un matto o no
[Musica]
perché hai azzeccato tutto è possibile
era mai adatta perché sembrano le
classiche domande trabocca del tipo no
da piccolo no poi è cambiato è diventato
ha capito che il videogame è una figata
come dire un cantante ma lunedì fece
diventare no no perché scusate ma ne sa
nulla stress che vuole i vari video su
youtube
certo la colf vabbè dai fotoni daniela
ragazzi dai gay riporta in alto in modo
nome di jacopo cosa scrisse sul si
svegli ma il gesto è il ricordo questo
come velocità c'eri anche tu quando hai
fatto problema che non mi ricordo la mia
posizione a si studia mai spaccato il
braccio che ha già tanti video e
iacopino ha fatto fuori giri
3 mai rimontato di poter arrivare
rimontato di brutto
vada come ribello con chi li menziona
mai fatto un video perché per
quest'ultimo anno amira garmin alle
tutti vegas
non è vero parigi dopo il video tutti
così più non con chi lo sci pvc che cosa
ricordo
zecchi me ne vado veramente incredibile
non puoi azzeccarla è impossibile non mi
dire che lei dc orte rispondo io ero
fissato la cosa più assurda è cambiato
per farti sbagliare psicologia inversa
vedremo poi ad erano sicuramente a
perché poi faremo seguito io faccio
mille loro come si chiama la madre di fa
vicina e sai come si chiama mia madre me
ne vado questa di sbagliato ma no ma
perché insomma abbiamo una serata cieli
di shannon mia madre non è un problema
una gran bella delle madri grazie a
questa è bella non ha senso a vincere e
valigie e va a vincere io lo sapevo lo
sapevo e la sapevo festa era sapevo come
battezza era ragazzo non è possibile
comunque io amo la mamma di famiglia dai
più il suggerimento se registrano 6 a
ieri si è lamentata di happy meal
l'assistente fatto la parodia dai
francesi perché fattore che lo prenderà
ad amsterdam
ma non legale alla saab rigenera la
ragazza di sasha come si chiamava
vigilia secondo me giuseppe manca
veramente io proverei carmela
incredibile non sono mai fatto beccare
cosa c'è chi sa cosa sia la cia la cia
sul fornello di favi j
cosa ci ha sul formato famiglia cosa ci
osno quanto un pennello un cuscino una
pentola era il cucciolo sapevo
magari vai a casa mia non so neanche i
fornelli manco la casa è un dettaglio e
per un pubblicità volevo fare vedere una
bellissima foto di jacopone basta a caso
voleste selezionate le mie foto sono
quanto in tv sono le tette cosa fatta
parigi lo speciale 10 milano milioni di
iscritti che 10 milioni di iscritti
facile ragazzi che va dopo facile troppa
e azzeccato certo ragazzi o mio dio ti
sembrava the void a giovani per stilare
una cosa pubblicato senza h evidente
lario io è da un vero vg è andato a new
york
anzi si sente cinque stadi macchina si
ieri no non sei manager new york tutto
culo allumino di uno sono confuso raga
io proporrei l'ultima insieme mai
insieme inutile che continuiamo a parigi
che lavoro fa e l'emanazione lo youtube
va in costruzione da un lego cosa
rispondono youtube si è sbagliato perché
lo youtuber non è un lavoro non vi siete
costruiti faccio il conosciute
ricostruzione va bene ragazzi da dire
che possiamo credere che questo video
ringrazio gli punt hellas per aver
partecipato sente molto più gravi di
quanto pensassi
nel prossimo episodio se io sono in
grado di tener testa a questo quiz sui
pantella poesia ma intanto passate anche
sul canale di pantera si spero che vi
sia piaciuto quel momento mi piace anche
vari istituti di ricerca
[Musica]